sébastien lapaque bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en ce joli matin
brumeux nous sommes à la flottille à
versailles un lieu qui vous est familier
puisque vous êtes versaillais et nous
sommes donc tout près du château dans
l'enceinte du parc voilà alors on a
beaucoup de choses à dire sur vous mon
cher monsieur d'abord vous êtes
versailles hier depuis combien de temps
depuis
préparant très longtemps voilà enfin
quand je me suis mariée en 1992 j'ai
habité quelques années à paris je suis
revenu à versailles en 1998 d'accord
pourquoi vous être heureux parce que
c'est une belle ville ça vient parce que
charles r j'aime les arbres j'aime la
nature et apparaît parfois c'est un peu
simple minérales comme vu un manque
d'accord et alors donc vous avez
plusieurs corde à votre arc si je peux
dire vous êtes à la fois écrivain c'est
ce qui nous amène aujourd'hui
vous êtes essayiste vous êtes critique
littéraire pour l'instant au figaro
littéraire bien sûr et aussi vous
collaborez à d'autres revues j'imagine
qu'elles sont elles un mariam par
exemple marianne oui à la vie
au monde diplomatique
partout on prend ma copine la place
d'accords et vous êtes aussi animé par
est ce qu'on peut dire trois grandes
passions je sais qu'il y en a d'autres
passions principal ya le brésil auquel
je compte sur lui manque déjà il ya le
vin auquel j'ai également consacré
plusieurs livres puis la troisième je ne
sais pas armes on m'avait dit le xviie
siècle 7e siècle oui c'est vrai aussi
j'aime beaucoup les auteurs du xviie
siècle c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup
de plaisir à me retrouver ici avoir
glissé le l'ombre de molière et de jean
de la fontaine dans les allées du parc
d'accord vous voulez retrouver parfois
la brise leurs fantômes ou oui c'est un
tome il ya charles perrault aussi que
j'aime beaucoup d'accord comment c'est
venu 7,7
vocation d'écrivain déjà petit oui bah
c'est vrai que c'est des choses
c'est toujours un peu mystérieux une
vocation
quelle qu'elle soit et leur une vocation
artistique peut-être plus mystérieux que
les autres vocations de vocation
d'écrivain c'est cette certitude que ce
qu'on veut exprimer sur le monde et la
vie qu'on peut exprimer sur le monde et
la vie on ne le fera jamais mieux
qu'avec à travers des mots donc
peut-être pour certains ce sera de
composer le sonate pour d'autres de
peindre un tableau mois il s'est trouvé
que c'était d'écrire voilà de 2,2 d'être
attentif aux mots c'était pour moi la
façon la plus forte intimement de d'être
en accord je dirais que le monde mmos
rejoignent voilà c'est pas des mots qui
flotte au-dessus de la réalité c'est des
mots qui collent au monde et voilà
chacun s'invente dans sa vie sa façon de
coller au monde oui
c'est à travers lui y en as il y en a il
y en a c'est en montant au sommet de
l'everest d'hôtes en allant sur la lune
et et puis on essaie de trouver les mots
justes pour voilà exprimer leur
sentiment sur le monde et la vie ce qui
est mon cas très bien alors c'est bien
de me parler de moi ça m'arrange parce
que justement on va aborder
ce thème des mots qui est présent dans
les cartes postales puisque vous venez
de sortir la théorie des cartes postales
un tout nouveau recueil et racontez moi
un peu alors comment est venue cette
idée déjà désir du bien dans le livre ce
n'est pas une idée justement est inédit
c'est une sensation au fait sensation
vous avez bien vu parce qu'en fait je me
suis rendu compte que la carte postale
est un objet universel à savoir que ça
touche toutes les catégories sociales il
ya des gens très simples qui peuvent
avoir beaucoup de plaisir à son biais
des cartes postales des écrivains
peuvent s'envoyer capitale beaucoup plus
élaboré on voir faire des verts des
alexandrins puisqu'on peut imaginer ça
peut être très simple comme très élaboré
ça peut être des enfants qui envoie les
qui s'envoient des cartes postales entre
amis à l'école mais aussi des enfants
qui envoient leurs grands parents ça
peut être des grands parents qui
envoient leurs enfants ça peut être pour
parler d'un voyage sa peau est pour vous
remercier quelqu'un d'un présent ça peut
être pour souhaiter un bon anniversaire
une bonne année là il en devient
dispositif tout ce village champêtre
voilà ça peut les visages familiers
amicaux et pourquoi pas même presque
professionnel on pourrait dire pour
remercier ou un client ou un contact de
zoophilie c'est drôle ce sont les modes
de communication contemporain oms ont
profondément bouleversé et à ce mode
présent siens de communication dans ta
carte postale en france en europe et en
autriche et en suisse qu'elle apparaît
c'est vers 1870
voilà ce qu'on peut appeler le boom de
la carte postale en france c'est au
moment de la belle époque les bourses a
vu que nous sommes à verser je vous ai
je vais amener quelques cas alors oui je
ne suis pas un collectionneur parce que
là vous avez la totalité de ma
collection sur versailles à nadal 6 1
début je ne suis pas à collectionner
mais bon c'est juste du plaisir voilà
moi quand je trouve chez un marchand de
livres anciens une carte postale qui me
parle
je l'achète voilà mais vraiment par
plaisir par collection c'est vraiment
une inspiration est ce qu'il est souvent
l'envoyaient à quelqu'un lui alors
souvent j'essaie d'en acheter qui sont
vierges de tout
extase de tout texte et là je mets un
timbre et je l'envoie alors quelqu'un va
recevoir une carte postale du bassin de
neptune à versailles un dimanche de
grand sault une photographie qui doit
être de la belle époque du début du
siècle avec un timbre de 2014 dont je
trouve ça drôle oui décalage dans le
temps et le voilà vous dites dans votre
livre parce que vous faites un petit peu
d'histoire à l'époque au début des
cash-flows celle-ci levée de courriers
par jour donc ça voulait dire qu'on
pouvait envoyer une carte postale et
avoir l'assurance que la personne la
reçoivent extrêmement rares comme les
mêmes décalé en rendez vous d'un quart
d'heure près fasse avaler encore la
peine c'était jouable et puis aussi
alors ça c'est vrai que pour nous hommes
et femmes de 2014 c'est également un
devoir un texte sur au dos d'une carte
postale il en a tout à l'heure ça nous
paraît un truc d'extracteur
met donc en fait la carte postale a eu
cet effet cette grande moment de drogue
au moment de la belle époque elle était
tombée un petit peu on oublie finalement
fallait jusqu'à la première guerre
mondiale il ya énormément de carte
postale à mon avis c'est parce que les
gens avaient pas le même rapport que
nous avons avec la photographie c'est à
dire que déjà pardon je vous coupe mais
vous vous dites nombreux titres au
départ les gens écrivaient carrément sur
la wii alors là vous avez un exemple
vous avez un bon exemple lorsque vous
prenez 7 4 pour celles de l'otan et
réservoirs et séjourner proust quand il
venait à versailles qui
il était il était bien marquer sa cape
postal ce côté qui est donc le recto est
exclusivement réservé à l'adresse de
pierre que l'adresse de la personne de
l'autre côté il ya la photographie le
timbre qui collait way et vous avez je
t'embrasse m donc un petit les clients
n'a en fait le but était surtout
d'envoyer une photo et le texte était
presque avec d'autres types
d'accessoires blessés il est vraiment
tout petit alors qu'après long des 1 400
personnes on est d'une cape salle du
trianon palace en 1919 au moment du
congrès de la plaie derrière également
le parlement avec une carte postale ci
qui elle est vierge mais a été juste tu
aimerais tu as leurrer on voit bien que
à partir après 1904 les usages changent
il ya de l'autre côté du côté recto un
endroit pour la correspondance un
endroit by adrien et le timbre par
contre toujours collé sur l'image alors
nous nous avons
un change et des usages nous collons du
côté du recto leuthard et nous écrivons
et l'image el maali intacte on n'y
touche pas sauf on peut s'amuser à faire
une croix parlons donc pour envoyer une
carte postale de vacances pour montrer
dans lequel maisons ont résidé oui et
bien face au wac pourrait
entourer une plage et voilà
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous
avez lu usage pro b de la carte postale
dont dans l'entre-deux-guerres dans les
mêmes dans les années 50
les sardes et sont un petit peu et c'est
aussi ça qui a été très important qui a
déclenché une envie d'écrire ce livre
c'est devenu wade depuis je suis pas 10
ou 15 ans un objet à nouveau très
actuelle les sharks je suis dans mon
livre trois cents millions de cartes
postales vendues
j'ai même voulu dans le syndicat des
imprimeurs des électeurs de cartes
postales qui a annoncé un chiffre moi
j'ai écrit mon livre dans deux durant
l'été 2012 il syndicats cartes postales
en buvant dyadun vie tellement pour
l'honneur d'aragon
j'ai vu qu'un teaser de capital annoncée
de 350 millions alors je sais pas ce qu
une progression annoncée comme lyon ça
me paraît beaucoup mais ça paraît déjà
mais en tout cas je pense que faire du
fn voilà c'est ça c'est ça qui m'a qui
m'a touché un capot ça je me dis cet
objet qui devrait être totalement désuet
voilà alors à l'heure de l'ue sms avec
du texto de facebook du tweet est re
devenu un objet de notre vie quotidienne
on est alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
l'aspect un peu collection d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que jamais ces cartes
postales anciennes pour le clin d'oeil
mais c'est aussi j'aurais dû en prendre
quelques unes en couleurs on aurait pu
acheter
chez n'importe quelle librairie ou
marchand de journaux à versailles et qui
sont pas destinés uniquement aux
touristes les gens s'envoient des cartes
postales moi je vois me j'ai une fille
de 17 ans avec ses amis sans voix des
cartes postales or c'est dit c'est
peut-être pas l' usage
c'est un usage différent c'est plus pour
un usage d'un peu ludique voilà des
classes d'âge et c'est un exercice de
style aussi les floridiens c'est ça le
fond de mon livre c'est de revenir aux
maux il faut choisir
vous parlez de poésie automatique voilà
c'est ça il ya quelque chose à mon avis
est que l'exposition automatique ces
deux bouts de choisir des mots hazard
qui vous viennent voilà on peut parler
des haïkus japonais
je pense que oui je pense aux jeux des
surréalistes aussi aux improvisations et
je pense que effectivement la carte
postale dans l'usagé que nous en faisons
aujourd'hui est un jeu littéraire est un
genre littéraire à part entière un jeu
littéraire un exercice de style mais
aussi pourquoi celle apportée tous ces
contrairement à ça permet à chacun de la
littérature qui dirait minuscule
apporter tous écrire une pièce de
théâtre ou un sonnet c'est pas là le
porter tous pareils joliment tour de 1
400 est à la portée de tous donc c'est
la littérature la plus universelle tout
le monde peut s'y essayer sans compter
bien sûr bon peu complément on peut
effectivement simplement écrire je
t'embrasse comme les sept personnes dans
la salle demain matin c'est
malheureusement pas une carte de marcel
programme avaya que c est en fait
en fait on peut précédemment cesser
aussi s'amuse à écrire un poème vous
parliez de haïku et s'il s'amusait à
faire à des alexandrins donc on peut
l'élaborer puis les enfants aussi le
savent bien on peut aussi écrire sa
carte postale avec différents crayons de
couleur oui on peut aussi faire des
simples l'a créée donc il ya toutes
sortes de choses c'est vraiment un jeu c
voilà c'est qu'est ce que c'est un
plaisir partagé universel et c'est pour
ça que ça m'a paru intéressant de
célébrer cette présence inattendue de
cet objet venu de de long des siècles
passés n'a peut-être pas des siècles
passés puisque
1870 enfin se dire que c'est à dire que
la scarpe aux salles aujourd'hui à 144
ans à huy lequel aurait pu être devenu
totalement est morte après avoir - idée
pour conclure oui c'est qu'en fait c'est
quoi la différence entre une carte
postale et un sms il y avait un message
pour ce message de façon ailier mais la
carte postale est un objet donc la
carène seul d'état cadeau c'est à dire
que si vous êtes content que je vous ai
envoyé cette jolie carte postale du
bassin dès qu il voulait accrocher sur
votre réfrigérateur vous le mettez dans
votre bureau soit les travées de votre
bibliothèque
un jour vous avez un cadeau alors qu'un
sms vous avez un message mais une fois
que vous avez fait les messages vous
n'avez plus rien donc ça ça reste voilà
un cadeau c'est un cadeau en plus oui
qui fait plaisir d'un coup alors il ya
des gens qui vont nous expliquer que les
sms et moi chaque la carte postale mais
enfin une carte postale ça coûte happart
même parfois moins d'un euro et des
quartiers à 5 centimes un timbre sac ou
de 63 centimes je crois maintenant donc
on est tout petit peu plus qu'un euro on
vous acheter un timbre et de câpres
scène vous rentrez dans un café vous
demandez qu'on vous prête un crayon
pouvait faire un câlin sedan de quoi
écrire on veut envoyer à un ami d'ami
quelque chose qui le fera plaisir pour
un euro donc voilà ça va c'est en plus
oui c'est un cadeau pour temps de crise
on va écouter sébastien j'attends que
vos nouvelles oui une petite carte me
fera plaisir pour m'annoncer le prochain
livre voilà c'est comme un livre
s'appelle théorie de rio de janeiro
pourrait partir brésilienne fab je vous
enverrai brésil j'espère merci merci